هل يعوض شبح كورونا الاطلال براسه في ذكره
الثالثه لم تتعافى البشريه تماما من موجات
الجائحه رغم اعتبار القيود والاغلاقات
جزءا من الماضي الا في مسقط راس الفيروس
تعيش الصين واجواء عصيبه تعيد التذكير
بمثل هذه الايام من اواخر 2019 واوائل
2020 مليون اصابه يوميه تسجل في اقليم
شرقي البلاد والتوقعات تشير للمزيد خلال
ايام وفي شنغهاي حثه السلطات الناس على
البقاء في منازلهم خلال اعياد الميلاد لكن
مستشفى بالمدينه توقع ان يصاب نصف السكان
البالغ عددهم 25 مليون بالفيروس بحلول
نهايه الاسبوع المقبل وتوقعت حكومه مقاطعه
جينشي شرق البلاد ان يصاب 80% من سكانها
اي نحو سته وثلاثين مليون شخص بالفيروس
حتى مارس اثار قادم
تصاعد اعداد الاصابات لم يقنع قطاعات من
المواطنين بقبول استمرار القيود الوقائيه
التي لم تكت تنقشع طوال السنوات الثلاث
الماضيه فاندلعت احتجاجات قبل اسابيع الغت
السلطات على اثرها مطلع ديسمبر اجراءات
الاغلاق والفحوص والحجر وقيود السفر التي
اثرت سلبا على النمو الاقتصادي انتقال وصف
بالمفاجئ من سياسه صفر كورونا ذات القيود
الثقيله الصارمه الى التوسع في تخفيف
القيود لكن على واقع تزايد الاعداد مؤخرا
اعلنت لجنه الصحه الوطنيه بالصين التوقف
عن نشر البيانات اليوميه لاصابات فيروس
كورونا ووفياته
تخفف السلطات قيود الوقايه لكنها تشدد
قيودا اخرى على التناول الاعلامي للفيروس
ومستجداته والرغم الاعداد الصادمه تواصل
وسائل الاعلام الحكوميه التقليل من خطوره
الموجه الجديده
المراوحه الصينيه بين الاغلاق وعدم
الاغلاق تطرح تساؤلات في ظل التصاعد
اللافت في اعداد الاصابات حول مخاطر
اندلاع موجه عالميه جديده تنطلق من الصين
نحو عالم اثقلته قيود الجائحه فاز لها
اتراه يتحمل العوده اليها طوعا او كرها